ciao a tutti ragazzi qui è niki box qua
fa vj siamo due ragazzi in 16 anni tutti
e due abbiamo appena iniziato
abbiamo appena fatto questo canale di
share il gaming ciao a tutti ragazzi cui
è di chi box equa fa vj siamo due
ragazzi di 26 anni tutti e due abbiamo
deciso abbiamo deciso aprire questo
canale dice questo niente aveva beh va
bene così questo diciamo senza voce in
dieci anni me cambia o perso signori e
signori sono
emozionato contento felice di questa
vita spero di essere riuscito a regalare
un po di sorrisi anche a voi in questi
dieci anni e sono con altrettante
mozione qua con mio fratello nick i box
perché senza di lui io non sarei qua
gravi per piangere così li fa piangere
ed hanno preparato niente quello che
penso esattamente dieci anni perché
primo video ragazzi la youtubers lo
abbiamo fatto nel il 24 luglio del 2011
alle 11 siamo esattamente dieci anni
dopo quel video
abbiamo deciso di aprire un canale il
the chair and gaming joniche box e luca
che salutiamo
siamo qui oggi siamo ancora superamici
siamo fratelli praticamente di report
pro bene è passato questo momento
totalmente non preparato dov'è il corso
negli oscar quando vai a braccio a che
non ho uno strano perché in terapia era
era candidato però purtroppo con la
comunque passiamo alla seconda parte del
video dove solo grazie amici però per
aver creato salterebbero e grazie a
tutti voi al nettop e quindi ragazzi non
ho nessuna scaletta per questo video non
ho niente perché penso che la miglior
scaletta per un video del genere sia il
cuore parte le cagate filosofico
comunque ci credono sul serio questa
frase questo per me equivale a un
traguardo equivale un traguardo di
milioni di iscritti nel senso che dieci
anni su youtube e ragazzi sono tanti in
questi dieci anni mi è cambiata
totalmente totalmente la vita da ragazzo
non popolare perché non lo ero per
niente di un paesino a diventare lo
youtube per più seguito in italia per
adesso non lo so saranno 6 anni 6 mei
controtesi dimenticassero rifare youtube
potrebbe arrivare anche forse fino a 10
e allora tutto questo come è stato
possibile effettivamente come può un
ragazzo che non si caga nessuno di pezza
a diventare il primo in italia per tutti
questi anni è troppo è una cosa pazzesca
ogni volta che registrava un video ogni
volta che montava i miei figli
anche se ci mettevo 5 6 ore a vito
all'inizio da un casino perché non
sapevo fare non si può montare non stavo
registrare io lo stavo facendo perché
quella roba per me era come un
videogioco queste stessi giocando
qualcosa e mi divertivo talmente tanto
che questa cosa è stata trasmessa a
tutti coloro che mi hanno scoperto in
quel periodo quando sono iniziate ad
arrivare le prime views i primi
traguardi di iscritti
la mia vita è totalmente cambiata è
totalmente cambiata perché grazie a
youtube ho scoperto cosa voglio nella
vita ho scoperto che mi piace viaggiare
scoprire scopa tutte queste cose che ho
da quando ero piccolo non mi sarei mai
immaginato di cre poi comunque si cresce
a prescindere non è che senza youtube
sarei comunque un'altra persona rispetto
a quando avevo 16 anni ma io che mi ha
dato proprio voi mi avete dato
l'opportunità di crescere nella maniera
più curiosa che potesse mai accadere ad
un ragazzo timido di 16 anni di un
paesino in culo a torino o anche
combattuto la mia giovinezza perché
comunque grazie a youtube
quando cammino per strada qualcuno di
ferma quando vado a degli eventi riesco
a guardare le persone dritte negli occhi
quando parlo perché una cosa che ad una
volta non riuscivo a fare i miei amici
losanna io giochi mi ha cambiato la vita
lo ripeto un'altra volta non solo per la
fanno ma perché mi ha dato modo di
vivere ora se avete notato
nell'ultimo periodo negli ultimi mesi
stanziate da inizio anno i numeri su
youtube
in generale sono un po calati anche i
miei vedete che non faccio più le news
dei tempi d'oro
qualcuno mi sta scrivendo il suo periodo
come sto io moralmente guardando i
numeri e venendo che non sono quelli di
una volta non ho mai dato una risposta
perché effettivamente non c'è mai stato
modo ora che ci penso però io sono
totalmente sereno ma questo perché per
diversi motivi il primo tra tutti è che
come vi ho detto prima ho iniziato per
gioco e per divertimento e per passione
oggi lo faccio per le stesse motivazioni
quindi se non ci sono i numeri di una
volta c'è l'importante che io stia bene
che mi diverta con la passione non deve
mai scomparire e non posso fare video
solo per fare chiuso cioè non è non sono
io quindi preferisco di gran lunga a
fare meno chiuse ma a fare quello che
questo è categorico sono proprio fatto
così quindi la risposta è che se i miei
numeri non sono più come ai tempi d'oro
non è che non me ne frega niente perché
mi viene una cagata però non mi importa
così tanto come potreste pensare ho
fatto già molto più molto molto molto di
più di quello che potessi mai sperare di
fare che va benissimo così quindi
ragazzi io veramente vi abbraccerei uno
per uno se potessi dopo tutti questi
dieci anni ancora rimanga un ventilatore
nello studio quindi non so magari potrei
investire qualcosa in quello che
guadagna tema caldo a parte se ci
pensate mettetevi nei panni di un
ragazzo di 18 19 anni mi divertivo come
un matto mi facevo comunque un culo così
perché ci si fa ancora ovviamente lo
spiegate l'avete sentito mille volte
cosa c'è dietro un video di youtube
quanto tempo ci ha messo la gente ad
assimilare che questo è veramente un
lavoro mi fa proprio vedere come
l'essere umano si evolve in altri sensi
ovviamente in italia ci si pente di più
però vabbè si sia passati dal niente a
ha qualcosa da qualcosa da qualcosa tu
kat resterà bassa però avete capito
siamo arrivati dieci anni dopo a fare
questo video io vi ringrazio
grazie di essere qui per il nostro anzi
neanche mio nostro a questo punto
compleanno i ragazzi vi abbraccio e vi
voglio bene davvero con tutto il mio
cuore vi voglio bene
grazie
ciao a tutti ragazzi qui è niki box si
faccia di fare i file